[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui en bas sur une vidéo
qui sort des sentiers battus puisque on
va parler du land screen
alors attention ça tourne action est mon
prêt de jeux de mots alors c'est une
vidéo qui va être sûrement un peu plus
courte et plus rapide que d'habitude
mais là je vais vous parler du hand
szpiner vous savez ce que c'est je veux
pas vous représenter cet objet il ya
quelque chose d'intéressant à savoir
d'où vient cet objet comment du jour au
lendemain quelqu'un inventait rhône
szpiner la personne qui a raté cet objet
c'est une femme elle s'appelle catherine
ringer ringer ça dépend ce qu'il propose
au salon de natal puisque usines
américaines bien avant que ce jouet
explose sur internet en partie grâce à
dr no sumann et plein d'autres personnes
catherine avait importé en 1997 elle
avait déposé un brevet un vrai brevets
d'invention qui s'appelle le spinning
toy dont le seul but est de s'occuper
les doigts en le faisant tourner
l'entraîneur et à la basse tenez vous
bien elle avait inventé ça pour pouvoir
jouer avec sa fille qui était malade
donc aller chercher en bas une activité
qui pouvait les relier ensemble doit le
pouvais jouer ensemble ça n'existait pas
à l'inventer ça c'est malin sa fille qui
avait 16 ans à l'époque avec
malheureusement une liasse tenais donc à
la menthe se jouer elle dépose le brevet
à le propose à des marques comme hasbro
et d'autres marques qui refusent le
joueur en fait ça les intéresse pas du
tout et en 2005 elle ne renouvelle pas
le brevet qui coûte 400 dollars par an
en fait pour elle quand tu dépose un
brevet faut payer tous les ans pour que
le brevet sont maintenues elles ne le
renouvelle pas non pas parce qu'il y
croit plus mais simplement parce qu'elle
a de graves problèmes financiers et
qu'elles n'arrivent pas le pays joue est
sorti de l'ombre a complètement explosé
au point qu'il y ait des demandes qui
n'arrive pas être satisfait dans ce
moment dans les magasins et il ya même
des endroits tellement c'est fort on
l'interdît des écoles où c'est interdit
j'ai le site spinner liste.com que je
vous invite à visiter qui recense même
les écoles où c'est interdit aux états
unis c'est quand même 32 % des écoles le
magazine the guardian est allé
l'interviewer récemment il a pu
constater en fait avec les points
c'était compliqué à la règle même pas
payer sa facture de téléphone
elle ne perçoit rien aucun droit je
viens du tout surtout les dérivés
d'ailleurs tous les rounds szpiner qui
existe et ce qu'ils sont inventés en ce
moment quotidiennement celle là
tellement traumatisée qu'elle a fait des
recherches et alors ça j'ai pas ses
sources mais elle a constaté qu'il ya
seulement 3 % des créateurs comme ça dit
dès qu'ils perçoivent de l'argent plus
tard alors qu'au final sont jouées son
invention son idée est partout que ça
fait un tabac commercial que c'est en
train d'être utilisés pour aider à la
concentration d'enfants autistes et elle
elle a une fille qui est encore malade
aujourd'hui de cette maladie auto immune
qui est l'ami est émis
elles touchent rien c'est ouf ou pas là
je sais je suis pas en train de faire
une vidéo habituels sur cette chaîne
comme j'ai un peu de personnes qui
m'écoutent et peut-être que vous kiffez
vous aussi les andes szpiner je voulais
vous raconter l'histoire de ce jouet et
surtout que catherine a lancé un site en
fait un espèce de profonds ding pour
sortir le jouet d'origine je sais vous
avez sûrement déjà un dinar mais vous
pouvez aller faire un tour sur le petit
starter qu'à l'annoncé en contrepartie
vous recevrez le vrai en szpiner
d'origine tel qu'il a été pensé mais si
vous avez déjà un que vous n'avez pas
besoin d'autres vous pouvez faire comme
moi et demandé aucune contrepartie
mettre une petite somme il ya que 96
contributeurs à la besoin de 23 mille
dollars pour lancer le projet et il ya
juste 6000 $ je trouve ça dingue je me
dis ici toutes les personnes quoi jeter
un oeil szpiner on prenne un peu le
mécanisme et ne verse que un euro sans
demande de contribution aucun mea le
dépasse de ouf son plafond donc j'avais
envie de vous en parler voilà j'espère
que vous apprécierez quand même la vidéo
même si c'est particulier j'espère
qu'elle sera pas trop disloqué au
contraire que sera liker et partagez
c'est pas un grand engagement mais c'est
juste une pensée pour quelqu'un qui a
vraiment besoin
quelle petite fille malade qui s'est
fait spolier d'une idée qui lance une
idée par derrière mais qu'arrive même
pas la financer je pense que nous à
notre petite échelle en mettant un euro
sur le délire on peut l'aider mais
aujourd'hui c'était une vidéo
supplémentaire faut pas l'avoir comme en
remplacement d'une vidéo habituels mais
en vidéo en plus et si vous voulez lui
mettre un petit message de soutien en
français ou en anglais dans les
commentaires n'hésitez pas à le faire
je ferai un scream de tout ça et je lui
enverrai avec un petit don auxquels vous
n'avez pas à participer je ferai
moi-même
allez on se retrouve jeudi pour la
prochaine vidéo jeudi soir un peu tard
je pense ciao